we were already thinking
about going to bed, I began to go to the
kitchen, I think we’ll drink some water, I hear
some rustling,
I threw a cup and ran to the
bathroom, my husband was from here, and everything started to
fall, it turns out that the projectile
hit the neighbors
and all these doors
knocked out our doors then
that’s all these doors at the neighbor’s, there are 2 of them, they
fell into our corridor here,
I work for Nikolaev bainer, he
works for our company, so I
’m just on vacation now, and from Tuesday I
’ll go to work and
hope to work some more, well, how will
it be now,
I was sheltered in general  Well, there were a lot because
we drove through a lot of tanks, there are a lot of them and
a lot of military ones,
especially the collapse for some reason, and ours are weaker,
well, for some reason you have a million of them, of
course, at 200,000
we are still visible bt
and
I just started heavily bombing our
village
yesterday at 9:  00 happy or rocket fund
guy
tail
we ate save the baby
where it hits on the door close